bella tutti i ragazzi benvenuti e questo
il nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi
siamo finalmente sud lander girl me
l'avete chiesto in 50mila famiglie ma
cos'è sto lander girl che mi portava
avanti da secoli che volevo fare è
finalmente riuscito a farlo allora vi
dico subito che non si chiama lander
goldman nome che ci ho dato io perché se
era troppo lungo e si chiama dream dream
of the dead knights of the blood dead
non mi ricordo il titolo che trovate in
alto non me lo ricordo mai ogni volta me
lo rileggo prima di iniziare il video
per ricordarmelo ma non me lo ricordo
mai non c'è verso quindi non ci provo
neanche comunque è il titolo che vedete
in alto è la denominato slang perché più
veloce è per un semplice motivo che
adesso andiamo a vedere premo subito
stato così non mi annoio biglietto solo
queste nel cervello così riesco a
prendermi infarti giusti
ok perfetto staff game
allora perché lander girl perché allora
innanzitutto vi spiego perché c'è un
filmato iniziale ed è un gioco indie non
ho mai visto in vita mia un indie con un
filmato iniziale è infatti sta cosa
epica non non so come mai comunque per
chi lo vuole scaricare vi dico in
anticipo link lo trovate nella
descrizione ora partiamo subito che
siamo mezzi addormentati non so dove a
ripeto io non ci ho mai giocato soltanto
ho letto i vostri c'è chi me l'ha
consigliato mi ha scritto che cos'è e ha
lasciato degli screen e mi sembrava
carino
comunque c'è un filmato della ragazza
viene uccisa torturata e poi appeso a un
albero che adesso vedrete e ho visto
negli screen bassa è praticamente lo
scopo di questo gioco a quanto mi avete
detto poi non so se è proprio così e
trovare queste sei lacrime che sono
cristallizzate in una foresta dove noi
siamo sperduti ovviamente non si sa
perché è questa ragazza appesa
all'albero no e c'è anche proprio nel
gioco sera
in giro adesso veniamo in giro nella
foresta è capace che la troviamo e
dobbiamo recuperare tutte ste 6 lacrime
sparse a caso e non è così facile perché
mentre cercheremo lo spirito di questa
ragazza qui cercherà d
detto in parole che non sono molto
vigili cercherà di stuprargli ecco così
qui iniziamo subito sixty years sixty
orsi xvi grace fire and space and bring
them to my 3
non ci ho capito un cazzo da lei ha
capito six tir si vuol dire sei lacrime
e basta e poi devo portarle all'albero
si praticamente bisogna trovare queste
lacrime qui e portarle all'albero della
ragazza che è appesa che avete visto nel
filmato come potete notare gioco notate
anche i dolci suoni che si sentano di
sottofondo già mica go addosso prova
bene
notate che una specie di lamentazione
un'unione tra silent hill
he has land erano già trovato una
lacrima ragazzi ok così prende con sé ed
è una valigia i ragazzi la prima lacrima
trovata subito mi avete letto che è
difficilissimo trovarle io noi già
trovata una non sono fatto magari culo
però vabbè è già una ce l'abbiamo sì
diciamo una volta trovate tutte devo
andare dal posto dove c'è sta ragazza
appesa all'albero volendo ci posso
andare adesso ma non so dove dato che
non vedono accetta di minchia è
dimenticato di dirvi potete scaricarlo
in descrizione se volete il gioco perché
vi lascio il link
ok comunque se non l'aveste già notato
sto girando a caso perché io proprio non
so dove andare non ho la più pallida
roba
ok raga trovato qualcosa è una specie di
carro si mezzo diciamo inagibile barili
perfetto non ci sono lacrime però
ok perfetto me ne vado di qua perché
tanta inutile non ci sono lacrime
ok ok 6 ferma oddio oddio o mio dio è
raccapricciante è sparita la nebbia e
c'è la moglie dello slider che mi sta
fissando non notate anche voi che sia
sexy baby e di sicuro è molto snella ok
vi prese è scomparsa ok ok ragazzi
no non mi piace non mi piace per niente
se me la trovo così per caso in giro
sono cazzi miei ve lo dico subito
diciamo che mi hanno detto molti di voi
che se ti prende comunque se ti fa
spaventare perché capita adesso che ti
vede tipo da lontano ma se non c'è
interferenza perché ovviamente non è
come lo slang però se ti prende ti fa
venire un infarto molti di voi mi hanno
detto così io non ci tengo proprio
neanche ma neanche da lontano a vederla
infatti me ne stavo per andare fortuna
sono andata prima lei forse faccio qui
paura io comunque robot ragazzi
scusatemi se ogni tanto faccio dei tagli
però non sapendo dove andare e non tipo
anche sociale ho trovato ho trovato il
posto ragazzi ok vedete la tipa appesa
all'albero qua ci sono ok
dovrebbe esserci la prima lacrima da
qualche parte non c'è va bene forse
riappaiono tutte quando le prendo tutti
insieme
praticamente il gioco dovrebbe da quanto
ho capito che da quello che mi avete
detto la tip e appesa all'albero noi
dobbiamo raccogliere tutte e sei le
lacrime e farle apparire in stipsi
strani ok perfetto quindi vado perché
tanto quando ci sono lacrime
tornerò poi alla fine se riuscirò a
vincere sì come no
ok la vedo di nuovo ok perfetto io me ne
vado a me ne vado me ne vado me ne vado
me ne vado mi va bene che ancora non mi
carica come lo slider ad esempio che te
lo trovi in faccia e quindi finché sta
lontana va bene oddio cosa sto posta
ragazzi ho trovato un mega gazebo in sé
lander c'era il mega deal dopo c'è il
mega gazebo fantastico c'è un'altra
lacrima cazzo si chiuso tutto era una
trappola dove sono salve è permesso
ok ragazzi siamo entrati in casa di
dalla signora slann der mi non mi sembra
molto ospitale però non facciamogli
scortesie proseguiamo
oddio è raccapricciante veramente ho
paura di andare avanti non c'è permesso
paura di trovarmi la in un angolo così a
caso
ecco fatta dio santo nicchia ragazzi ho
perso dieci anni di vita
ok ragazzi l'avevo detto che mi sarebbe
saltata addosso ma non me l'aspettavo
veramente l'avevo detto per scherzo
ok ragazzo di uscire basta voglio uscire
fatemi uscire ragazzi sto girando da 21
a recco e ha di nuovo perfetto non la
vedevo da un pezzo o luce luciano c'è la
luce la luce luce fatevi uscire ai
dinghy again hi can give them searching
mi escape punishment frasi a caso in
inglese ma fate riuscire ok forse se mi
concentro apriti certo la cosa un cazzo
perfetto laga c'è una scritta inutile io
non ci tengo ad andare di nuovo lì ma
devo andare anche se c'è la tipa devo ok
forse ciò avremo di nuovo e scapperò
come un bambino impazzito no non c'è più
perfetto non solo andare ragazzi ragazzi
non ha idea di come abbia fatto entrare
qui dentro ma non riesco più ad uscire
e troppo labirintico di qua forse non ci
sono ancora passato però vediamo qua è
chiuso si è chiuso anche qui in fondo
proprio non so dove andare
no è aperto ok ok ok ok forse non è che
la devo seguire anche se non ci tengo
molto però l'unica strada è questa
ragazzi ok ok ok ok ok j
ok che bel culetto
speriamo che lo slang non si cazzi se
n'è andata perfetto domanda di qua si è
fatto centro ma l'uscita
ok allora ho trovato la seconda lacrima
ragazzi
ok perfetto salve bene siamo a 2 fa chi
è già qualcosa ragazzi perché non me
l'aspettavo veramente di riuscire a
trovare l'uscita ormai avevo perso le
speranze sappiate quando vi arrende a
cazzo no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no non ci ha fatto
stagione merita l'ergastolo
[ __ ] non è cioè io tutto tranquillo
che esco di casa ma no anche fuori deve
rompere i [ __ ] non c'è verso ok
ragazzi mi ha però sono creativo cioè
ero tutto occupato a ridere ea morire
d'infarto
però non ho capito perché sono ancora
vivo non è che ho iniziato no forse c'è
puoi guarire fino a un tot di volte
ragazzi comunque non mi ricordo perché
quando mi avete consigliato questo gioco
l'avevo letto la descrizione e mi avete
detto che se forse mi pare che mi avete
detto che se vuoi un tot di volte poi
alla fine muoio definitivamente però non
mi ricordo quante volte e soprattutto
non mi ricordo se è vero forse me lo sta
diventando di adesso perché l'ho letto
troppo tempo fa comunque ho trovato un
altro edificio spero lino ritrovano
intorno ok c'è una corda una campana
fantastico non c'è la campana persona e
là dentro key o una candela epico mi
servirebbe una lacrima però io mi prendo
quello che trovo che qua c'è
qualcos'altro lacrima no niente però la
candela c'e la cosa che mi serve la
candela ragazzi trovate mi l'utilità di
una candela ragazzi non ho ben capito
che cosa mi serve la candela però boh ok
ok ok ok ok
piano piano che già prima cioè capace
che ok ok ok
me ne vado vado sei brava calma perfetto
attentano muoverti ok ok ragazzi ho
preso la candela però non è da lì che
cosa mi serva cos'è sta roba
fai due passi trovi già qualcosa ho
preso la candela non so che cosa mi
serve ma sicuramente mi servirà qualcosa
più avanti ok ho trovato questo le
sembra
mi ricorda molto il bunker di world of
warcraft o di warcraft iii centro è un
labirinto fatto di assi di legno sì c'è
anche del fuoco e dato che è tutto di
legno non è consigliabile entrare qua
dentro ma io c'entro lo stesso
ok perfetto qua iniziamo il meglio che
lo spengo prima che va tutto a fuoco per
non riesco più a uscire perfetto bravo
sento dei rumori e molto ma molto
irrequieti ok sto spegnendo tutti i
fuochi ragazzi probabilmente dallo
spegnerli tutti ami apparirà un'altra
lacrima forse perché diciamo per farle
apparire non devi entrare nel posto tipo
islandese ma devi anche fare delle
determinate azioni devi compiere allora
siamo entrati da lì perfetto allora qua
non ci sono andato semi e se mi appare
qua dentro non so come faccia scappare
ragazzi e sono tre ragazzi sono entrato
ma non so piu come uscire ho sentito un
rumore di campanelle forse è apparsa la
lacrima però non ideali dove sia apparsa
a farseli aspettate non vedo aspettate
non vedo fa che ci sia se e sono tre
credo ci sono tre
ok man mano ci sono state scene molto
molto dolci povera ragazza poverina
ok ok ok vedo una sagoma ma non mi
avvicino me ne vado la cosa più
difficile che in slang era tutto buio
invece qua è molto più annebbiato per
dire quindi non so bene
impossibile rientrassi ragazzi non posso
rientrarvi un posto del genere
ok ragazzi ho seminato la sagoma che non
è una che è sicuro che era lei però è
meglio evitare di andare a scoprirlo
quindi sono andaman e sono andato
scusate comunque se faccio appunto dei
tagli però veramente cos'è ok perfetto
ogni volta che parlo di sta cosa trovo
ah no questo è quella di prima e dove ho
trovato la candela che non mi è servita
assolutamente una minchia
veramente che cosa è servita la candela
boh non lo so qua non ho ancora capito
se deve aprire una lacrima cosa però qua
non posso fare nient'altro
quindi ok ok ok ok ok ok girogirotondo
casca il mondo mi hai [ __ ] in pieno
fa vige tra l'ato ragazzi ragazzi avete
presente tipo quando avete fatto magari
lo scherza qualcuno che mi seguiva voi
giravate in tondo a qualcosa e qualcuno
mi seguiva ricorrendovi sempre intorno a
questa cosa qui e poi voi magari per
andavate a e ve ne andate via lui
continuava a girare a casa un idiota è
per l'asl and her che poteva fare
tranquillamente così io ci sarei cascato
ok mi piace il fatto che sei molto
allegra però me ne devo andare tutto qua
ci sono rocce che non ho visto prima
ragazzi non vedo nulla è troppo buio c'è
un ministro dal rosso e nebbia non vedo
niente comunque ragazze notando il fatto
che è diventato tutto rosso quasi
sicuramente la prossima volta che muoio
muoio per sempre quindi non devo farmi
prendere non devo farmi prendere
assolutamente meglio che venne varato
perfetto corri corri corri corri corri
corri già prima mai [ __ ] nomi rifatti
di nuovo
ok non so che non so che cosa sto
edificio qui non è non è l'edificio
tutto e roccia pro come ci sarà una
lacrima in giro da qualche parte presumo
è talmente grosso mi ricordo oblivion
strada bloccata strada bloccata
no no macchia si esorcizza ok
vieni qua un abbraccio a fa vj thank you
for plains new heavies line tipo dall va
bene ragazzi è veramente impossibile
finirlo cioè io non so come fai ad
aiutarti in un gioco del genere era
arrivato a 3 su 6
fatemi sapere quanto arrivate poi il
download ve lo lascio in descrizione qui
sotto
quindi ragazze fatte un punteggio
migliore del mio scrivete mano sotto nei
commenti
niente lasciato un commento se vi è
piaciuto video mettete mi piace e
iscrivetevi alla pagina di facebook che
trovate sempre in descrizione è gente ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi